why'd you and your ex break up
you broke up with your ex cause he's
married do you want him to leave his
wife for you yeah
yeah you cannot make this up
we're here at Tortuga Country Music
Festival in Fort Lauderdale Florida
we're here for one reason we're here to
find out if country women make good
wives let's find out there's a song that
calls all my ex
that's right uh why did you and your ex
break up it was kind of a sugar daddy
situation and
you can't make this up back to being
controlled he was too controlling and he
told me I couldn't go out of state for
school he was paying for your life but I
wanted to be a material girl I wanted to
work and you want to be a Material Girl
In A Material World then if you want
someone not to tell you what you do why
get a sugar daddy well that's the
situation I was into the time take my
ATM card right now just get out of it
cheater
you were a cheater he was a cheater I'm
a loyal
okay so you broke up with them what when
you found out uh he cheated on me a
couple times so yeah so one time you
know shame on you
two times
you broke up with your act
cause he's married
you cannot make this up
I can't even answer mine he'll come and
Hunt me down you get the concerned look
on your face
please explain did you break up with him
or he broke up with you once he found
out he was married
no we're not talking about this okay I
broke up with him
if you want him to leave his wife for
you yeah there's a song that's called
All My Exes
living living she knows some stuff
home girl over here was about to knock
you out if you know that song about to
knock you out uh why did you and your ex
break up he couldn't handle this what
does that mean too much for him too much
like you're too Fierce you're too hot
you're too much too bold too bold too
much personality for him he's boring you
know that the future belongs to the Bowl
did you know that
exactly now you know because I told him
if he ever wanted to cheat he would have
to do with somebody better but she
wasn't better so I said well that's just
embarrassing at that point I mean he
broke up with me and times got hard and
he ran he just ran all right did you
want him back
yes Stand By Your Man
[Music]
um
I'm really independent and my ex was
very clingy I
don't know I like space he could not
commit
is that because you couldn't submit no
you just couldn't commit
ment he had had issues with keeping his
zipper zipped up
no thankfully not that he just was not
ready for a series already I just
cheated on me he cheated on you
sorry buddy what did you learn from that
relationship that will help you be a
better girlfriend or wife in the future
so first
respect yourself first and be happy with
yourself first and then you could be
happy with someone else and that goes
for both parties huh
probably not leave all the bad
situations under the rug because we kept
shoving problems communication
communication all right fill in the
blank Save a Horse
okay describe your ideal man
oh man just someone super nice hot
respectful big
he has four legs little tiny Paws he's
very excited to see me every time I come
home
okay so you got some beastiality going
on
let's be sick
I just said describe your ideal man you
describe your dog but I'm the sicko
describe your ideal man obviously he's
65 plus
you know you gotta fetish you know what
you want respect to you would you like
to weigh in on a real answer now or
around 32 34.
tall
banana soup but I could think I'd prefer
a guy who's just like
I don't know rugged
and has somewhere to move up in life and
it's in a bomb isn't a bum No Scrubs TLC
he's standing right there he's got some
tattoos he's tall he's [__] good
looking he's got some facial hair
muscular Bang Bang
all right I don't blame you okay
there's a song called Save a Horse Ride
a Cowboy every girl loves that song
describe your ideal man
AKA Cowboy tall dark and handsome see
Malik over there yeah
um tall and can protect me in any
situation anywhere anywhere we go
protector protector protect
um hard-working communication is always
important I like it when they can be
very like I don't know behind the scenes
they're like very soft
but soft what do you mean by that
like they like to act like they're a
tough guy but then like they're actually
like really sweet like behind the scenes
like they're a big ass mother they're
really a teddy bear yeah okay shout out
to the teddy bear crew out there
describe your ideal man pretty much the
same thing the only difference I'd say
is he's got to be funny if he's not
funny I can't I can't gotta have some
jokes he's gotta have some jokes okay
Family Guy respectful fun adventurous
and just open to you know learning
growing I'm very patient loving
supportive
um treats me like a princess every
single day okay Princessa Bueno thank
you guys so much for the interview you
guys are great Sports we really
appreciate you
[Music]